In Bayes rule, we have a hidden variable we care about--whether they have cancer or not.
But we can't measure it directly and instead we have a test.
We have a prior of how frequent this variable is true and the test is generally characterized
by how often it says positive when the variable is true
and how often it is negative and the variable is false.
Bayes rule takes a prior, multiplies in the measurement,
which in this case we assume to be the positive measurement to give us a new variable
and does the same for all actual measurement, given the opposite assumption about
our hidden variable of cancer and that multiplication gives us this guy over here.
We add those two things up and then it gives us a new variable and then
we divide these guys to arrive the best estimate of the hidden variable c given our test result.
And this example, I used the positive example is a test result
but it might do the same with a negative example.
This was exactly the same as in our diagram in the beginning.
There was a prior of our case, we have this specific variable to be true.
We noticed inside this prior, it can cover the region for which our test result applies.
We noticed that test result also apply when the condition is not fulfilled.
So, this expression over here and this expression over here corresponds exactly
to the red area over here and the green area over here.
But then we noticed that these two areas don't add up to 1.
The reason is that's lots of stuff outside, so we calculated the total area
which was this expression over here, pPos.
And then we normalized these two things over here by the total area to get the relative area
that is assigned the red thing versus the green thing and at this time by just dividing by the total area
in this region over here; thereby, getting rid of any of the other cases.